>> Lawrence: WELCOME BACK.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
LITERALLY LAUGHING AT AMERICAN
STRUGGLING WITH INSULATION.
CHECK OUT THIS RIDICULOUS ANSWER
FROM JOE BIDEN'S ENERGY
SECRETARY.
>> IN STURGIS, MICHIGAN, IT'S
$2.89 A GALLON.
I GUESS THAT'S BETTER THAN IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT IS THE GRAND PLAN TO
INCREASE OIL PRODUCTION IN
AMERICA?
>> [LAUGHS]
THAT IS HILARIOUS.
WOULD THAT I HAD THE MAGIC WAND.
IT'S A GLOBAL MARKET CONTROLLED
BY A CARTEL CALLED OPEC.
THEY MADE THE DECISION YESTERDAY
THAT THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
INCREASE BEYOND WHAT THEY WERE
ALREADY PLANNING.
>> Lawrence: WOW.
I DIDN'T THINK IT COULD GET
WORSE THAN KAMALA HARRIS GOOD
GOING WHEN SHE'S UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU KNOW WHO'S NOT LAUGHING?
THE ELECTRIC.
VIRGINIA, NEW JERSEY.
SMALLER DISTRICTS WHERE
PROGRESSIVES ARE LOSING CONTROL.
THE ELECTORATE.
AMERICANS ARE FED UP.
>> Jesse: IT REMINDS ME OF
OBAMA TALKING ABOUT THE MAGIC
WAND AS WELL WHICH DIDN'T COME
BACK TO HIM.
WHAT JOE BIDEN DID BEFORE THE
ELECTION IN VIRGINIA AND
NEW JERSEY, COMPLETELY
EMBLEMATIC OF THE DISCONNECT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HE IS IN GLASGOW.
HE IS IN ITALY TALKING ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND EMISSIONS
WHILE PEOPLE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL ARE TALKING ABOUT
CURRICULUM IN SCHOOLS,
INFLATION, OUR BORDER, A RETREAT
IN AFGHANISTAN.
ALL THE THINGS THAT PERTAIN TO
THEIR LIVES AND OUR NATION'S
HONOR.
THEY ARE PROTESTING JOE MANCHIN,
SAVED MY LIFE.
I'M ABOUT TO DIE BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THEY'RE
LISTENING TO THOSE THINGS.
IN THIS CASE THEY LISTEN SO MUCH
THAT THEY UNDERCUT OUR OWN
ENERGY DEPENDENCE AT HOME AND
THEN LAUGH AND SAY WELL, IT'S A
CARTEL, OPEC PEER WE NEED TO BEG
HIM FOR MORE OIL.
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO DO?
NOT CANCEL THE PIPELINE, NOT
CRUSH DOMESTIC OPPORTUNITIES AT
HOME.
THE ONLY ONE LAUGHING IS US AT
THEM WITH THE SHEER INCOMPETENCE
THEY'VE HAD IN HANDLING IT.
>> Lawrence: THERE'S A MESSAGE
COMING OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AT
LARGE THAT NOTHING IS HAPPENING.
IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT.
IT'S A DEMAND ISSUE.
EVERY SINGLE ISSUE THEY ARE
EXCELLING IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE REJECTING THEM.
WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO GET A
CLUE?
>> Dagen: THEY WON'T.
I WILL SAY AT THIS TABLE WHAT I
SAID WATCHING THIS, SCREAMING IT
OUT LOUD IN MY OFFICE BY MYSELF
LISTENING TO THE ENERGY
SECRETARY.
IS IT TOO MUCH TO ASK THAT THE
SECRETARY OF ENERGY ACTUALLY
UNDERSTANDS HOW THE ENERGY
SECTOR WORKS AND HOW ENERGY
PRODUCTION WORKS?
IS IT TOO MUCH TO ASK FOR HER TO
GIVE AT LEAST A SMALL DAMN ABOUT
THE SUFFERING THAT AMERICANS ARE
FACING AS THEY ARE TRYING TO SAY
DO I EAT SPAGHETTI FOR DINNER OR
DO I BUY A STEAK BECAUSE I'VE
GOT TO FILL UP MY CAR TOMORROW.
WHAT SHE SAID WAS TOTALLY
DISINGENUOUS.
THE UNITED STATES BROKE OPEC,
BROKE THE CARTEL.
WE BECAME A NET EXPORTER OF OIL
AND OIL PRODUCTS UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE BECAME THE WORLD'S SWING
PRODUCER.
THAT MEANS WE CONTROL THE GLOBAL
PRICE OF OIL BECAUSE WE HAD SO
MUCH SPARE PRODUCTION CAPACITY.
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT OPEC.
IT'S A GLOBAL COMMODITY.
WE CONTROL THE PRICE UNTIL YOU
TOOK A CHAINSAW, YOU AND YOUR
LIBERAL NUTS, TO ONE OF OUR MOST
VALUABLE INDUSTRIES AND TOOK THE
CHAINSAW TO OUR GLOBAL SECURITY.
YOU HANDED POWER TO NATIONS THAT
HATE US.
SHE CAN LAUGH ABOUT IT.
>> Lawrence: JESSICA, SHOULD
THE PRESIDENT SOME OF HER THE
OVAL?
HE CAMPAIGNED ON PRESIDENT
EMPATHY.
THIS DOESN'T SEEM VERY
EMPATHETIC.
>> Jessica: IS NOT A GOOD IDEA
TO LAUGH AT VOTERS.
YOU'RE LAUGHING AT VOTERS OF
YOUR OWN PARTY.
80% OF AMERICA IS UPSET ABOUT
INFLATION RIGHT NOW.
WIDE MAJORITIES OF EVERYONE,
INDEPENDENTS THE MOST ALONGSIDE
REPUBLICANS.
DEMOCRATS ARE FEELING THE HEAT
TO.
JOE BIDEN WON THIS ELECTION BY
BEING EMPATHETIC AND SAYING THAT
I CAN GET US THROUGH THIS GLOBAL
HEALTHCARE PANDEMIC.
YOU SAW THAT COMING UP.
YOU CAN'T DISMISS THE WAY PEOPLE
FEEL.
THIS WAS THE SAME THING THAT
THEY FOUND OVER AND OVER WITH
GETTING PEOPLE TO TAKE THE
VACCINE.
DON'T TELL THEM THAT THEY ARE AN
IDIOT BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
TAKE IT, EXPLAIN THE BENEFITS
AND THE SCIENCE AND HOW MUCH
BETTER LIFE WILL BE.
JEN GRANHOLM WAS A VERY GOOD
GOVERNOR, GREAT PERSON.
IT WAS A MISTAKE.
IT'S GOING TO BE RUN IN THE
MIDTERMS.
>> Lawrence: THAT WAS REALLY
NASTY.
JESSE, HERE'S THE PROBLEM, WE
COULD'VE DISCUSSED ENERGY POLICY
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
BUT IT WAS AN EMOTIONAL
CAMPAIGN.
WE DIDN'T GET TO TALK WITH THE
FACTS WHERE EACH CANDIDATE IN
THE MEDIA COVER FOR THEM.
SHE IS LAUGHING BUT THEY RAN ON
THIS.
THEY RAN ON THIS.
>> Jesse: JOE SAID AMERICA IS
BACK.
PROVE IT.
HE JUST GOT ON YOUR KNEES AND
BEGGED OPEC TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION AND THEY JUST GAVE
JOE THE MIDDLE FINGER.
THEY JUST GAVE JOE THE MIDDLE
FINGER, OPEC.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE BACK?
WE'RE GOING TO GET TALKED TO
LIKE THAT IN THE DESERT.
TRUMP USED TO JAWBONE THE
SAUDIS.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH WE ARE PAYING
TO PROTECT YOUR KINGDOM?
YOU WANT THIS WEAPONS PACKAGE TO
GO THROUGH A QUESTION LIKE YOU
WANT US TO STAY TOUGH ON THE
MULLAHS IN IRAN?
ALSO AS YOU WELL SAID, WE HAVE
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION UP NOT ONLY
IN OIL BUT A NATURAL GAS.
GAS PRICES, DOWNWARD PRESSURE ON
WORLD OIL PRICES.
HE FELL ASLEEP AT GLASCO IN
CLIMATE CONFERENCE WHERE HIS
BUDDY SAID WE ARE GOING TO
DESTROY PETROLEUM IN 30 YEARS.
WHAT YOU THINK THE SHEIKS SAID
THEN?
SLOW THINGS DOWN SO YOU CAN FEEL
THE PAIN.
FEEL SOME PAIN WITHOUT SOME OIL.
THEY ARE LAUGHING ALL THE WAY TO
THE BANK.
WAIT UNTIL WINTER COMES,
LAWRENCE.
DO YOU KNOW HOW EXPENSIVE HOME
HEATING PRICES ARE GOING TO BE?
HIGH HOME HEATING PRICES, HIGH
INFLATION, HIGH GAS PRICES.
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED SINCE THE '
70s.
REMEMBER WHAT CARTER SAID?
IF YOU'RE COLD, PUT A SWEATER
ON.
JESSICA IS GOING TO HAVE TO KNIT
YOU A SWEATER.
>> Jessica: THAT